la bête de la région comme d'habitude
voilà à huy des éleveurs du coin dans ce
supermarché la viande d'agneau et la
viande bovine sont locales elles
proviennent d'éleveurs située à 25 km
aux alentours un gage de qualité pour
les consommateurs c'est très bien c'est
pour ça que je viens ici je sais que la
viande vient du coin et c'est bien puis
c'est tout à fait dans la tendance de
manger local d'avoir des produits de
qualité le cahier des charges est précis
et exigeant les bêtes ne doivent pas
être trop grosse et doivent avoir moins
de 10 ans l'affichage est clair toutes
les informations sur la traçabilité du
produit sont visibles par le client
toutes les semaines
on change d éleveurs c'est ça tourne ça
tourne sait jamais le même
dans le cher cinq enseignes jouent
désormais le jeu du local environ 200
agneaux et 150 vaches sont vendus ici
chaque année c'est une démarche qu'on a
mis en place le en mars 2019 c'était une
demande des clients de permettre une
fluidité de la rémunération de la viande
aux producteurs de façon
de façon la plus simple possible simon
bronsard a lancé le collectif éleveurs
est engagé dans le cher en 2016 les
animaux envoyé en grandes surfaces
doivent être nés élevés et engraissés
sur la ferme une bête se vend environ à
80 le kilo sur le marché avec le
collectif le prix s'élève à environ 4
euros 65 ce qui permet une juste
rémunération
on a tous envie de vivre de notre métier
de faire vivre notre famille donc
la rémunération avec la base de coûts de
production permet d'obtenir sa même si
aujourd'hui c'est qu'un petit
pourcentage de nos maîtres qui passe
dans le circuit là on a pour hobby
ambition de le développer pour que ça
c'est un réel impact sur noël nos
exploitations pour le moment 35 éleveurs
adhère tout mouvement dans le cher
d'autres enseignes du département
devrait rejoindre le collectif et vendre
de la viande locale d'ici quelques mois
pour qu'éleveur et grandes surfaces soit
unie dans une démarche de qualité